[Music]
[Applause]
welcome everybody to lien review youtube
favorite show yes welcome welcome
finally finally I can learn about memes
from PewDiePie who what have I been
doing with my life until now I know
don't worry it's going to be ok you are
in safe hands I'm going to tell you all
about the means let's just not waste any
more time and let's get into the memes
please please feelings tell me what
means have you selected this week a main
review I need to know well the first
name is of course Savage Patrick it's a
spongebob meme which some pol
immediately makes me wanna gag and poke
my eyes out but it is actually quite
good it's a solid spongebob meme yes
when you secretly on birth control and
you ask him for Plan B money savage
Patrick my god this meme actually
started as a women's movement meme for
women to feel like there are also savage
because they are women can be Savage
yessuh when he giving you head start
telling you how good you taste when he
really is tasting another man not savage
Patrick oh I am so pleased that finally
women have a meme that they can enjoy
and be all like they're relatable and
such I'm all for the women's me movement
there's just not enough women in the
meme community scene and it makes me so
proud and I really cannot speak loudly
enough for them when you're writing his
face and you pee a little
this is actually disgusting ok I can no
longer approve of this meme when you
clapping [ __ ] from the back and her wig
fall off so you put it on
wait absolute savage my god this mean
place of course on the absolute mad Ladd
meme but let's be real here any mean
really responds on another meme they're
all just the same means ball together in
different disguises when you're getting
a prostate exam
but your doctor doesn't know it's
opposite day Wow fair deep ice nut comes
out of notes edit this out please bread
and bread bread and Brad number two
great great I'm sure they'll appreciate
that one great I can almost see what
this one says that look when someone is
trying to roast you and you about to end
his whole life in one sentence absolute
savage pantry when she's 13 but you got
the stiffy huh great
it's not just savage Patrick it's more
like taking advantage Patrick our decay
it's probably more suiting name when the
sex is trash so you spit on her back and
act like you nodded so you can dip
clearly this is a mean with an
intellectual seal of approval when you
drink water that's free savage Patrick
my god how far can they take this meme
you might say oh no when people say my
3d artwork is ugly creepy and disgusting
but that was the plan all along
oh my god oh man who made this crying
face crying face crying face emoji that
is disgusting despicable and I'm also
quite aroused I would let that Patrick
Savidge me if you know what I mean me
making pants in the groove chat
knowing I'm not gonna show up anyway how
relatable and joyous wow this meme is
already [ __ ] and it has barely even gone
started $3.99 everybody excellent
I think this one is actually my favorite
me leaving the pot in the sink because
it needs to soak why is it eyebrows to M
characters let's rate this meme
everybody first of all it's a spongebob
mean so we get to plus nothing because
it's a garbage that's right it's French
it belongs in the trash guys second of
all it gets one patrick Star that's all
it gets
[Music]
[Applause]
war tonight means the best finest of all
somehow fortnight is now the most
watched and streamed game on Twitch
reaching twice as many viewers as pub G
top G the game that started at all but
then this roblox ash looking game came
out of nowhere and said hey we're free
you can play play us please and their
screeding by his popularity a lot a lot
of means some of them starting off with
the theme of romance romans isn't dead
i'm hiding in a bush to take you back in
fortnight well real epic gamer dudes
like myself alright we wouldn't boast
about such such such acts okay we will
just do it like it was in any day sort
of beat alright I wouldn't boast about
me giving flowers to my girlfriend I
just do it because I'm a gentleman and I
wouldn't tell people oh yes I am hiding
it in a Shack right now just so I can
text you back baby I would be too good
to even have to do that I'm sending you
this text in a bush
stop crying face crying face crying face
crying face crying face crying face that
is absolutely hilarious and the funniest
thing I may have seen in my entire life
somehow the theme between fortnight in
relationship continues her he's probably
thinking about another woman him but I
shot him with a pump shotgun from close
range and it only did seven damage this
may be stolen and we already revealed it
somehow this relationship me in
fortnight ten years
find a girl who supports your fortnight
goes I hate for at night baby
you can do this look at your mistakes
and release them fix them dominate solo
oh my god baby I'm so proud of you
sometimes I think that Starling was
right not about the gulags but of course
about people playing fortnight as a
father it's my job to respect my son's
opinion dad yes my dear son pop G is
better than fortnight what is this what
is this huh
what is this are you trying to pretend
that it's somehow the better opinion to
prefer for at night over Pub G that's
like saying roblox is better than
Minecraft
that's like saying Hunger Games it's
better than Harry Potter you just cannot
do that you just can't say those things
hey kit you should play for tonight no
thanks I am already gay gunshots for
tonight people if you get shot in pub G
you gotta take it like a man and realise
hmm
gotcha in fortnight you just have to
build and then I can't I never played
the game action you don't know what
happens I guess you build stuff in the
game when Trump plays fortnight for the
first time and C said you can build
walls wow it made a rebounce everybody
look at that when your boy is crying
because his girl dumped him and you
realized he has more time to spend with
you and fortnight oh look how cute
is better than fortnight oh no it's
returned now
Babji is better than fine just because
you plebs can't afford to buy a video
game doesn't make it better you dumb
little Schmucks don't make me laugh
discussing a spot to land in fortnight
Battle Royale
you are playing a kids game you realize
that with kids cartoons this male just
played fortnight at the moment he stands
no chance of meeting that's right if you
are playing for tonight you are a
pathetic beta male that needs to just
stop you might as well be speedrunning
Hello Kitty Island Adventure because
that's about as pathetic as you are pop
G versus fortnight that's right solid
evidence
I got solid proof here that real men
plays pub G and nil whiny roblox
minecraft kids play fortnight it has
been proven hey it's the pop G Bros why
do you never remember my name I am a
sorry free to play pub G Oh absolute
sandwich whoa
before that memes gets of course a nine
out of six do we have time for bonus me
let's investigate sorry we didn't have
time for bonus mean perhaps next time
you will be more lucky
[Music]